yeah so we haven't really thought about
it very much I mean our basic our basic
view is that you know advertising is a
good way to support search and one of
the things that I can really put a huge
amount of praise on google for is that
they really pioneered the the low impact
unintrusive advertising on search and
and really realizing that you know the
best way to make money from search is to
be relevant with the advertising and
that's always been their principal and
it's a good principle so you know at
least initially that's kind of the
thinking I mean certainly we don't have
any sort of crazy weird business model
ideas like charging people to search or
charging people for listings right
that's a really bad model but we we're
really just saying well we know search
monetizes so if we can do a good job
we'll figure something out in fact one
of the fairly obvious places we might
want to turn is directly to Google to
partner with them for the ads I mean
that's they do a good job so you know
it's it's not a business that we're
interested in competing with Google on
right now so
what we already do we already have ads
so wikia everybody likes to talk about
the search project because it's kind of
the interesting thing that piques
people's interest but we have over six
thousand different wiki communities on
all kinds of topics like World of
Warcraft wiki is one of the most popular
and we do partner already with Google to
provide ads for those wiki's and well
seems fine